Thank you for joining
us for our hot topics.
Today, we're very lucky
to have Professor Michael
Lynn from Stanford.
Michael received his AC summa
cum laude in biochemistry
from Harvard.
And he followed that with a PhD
in biological and biomedical
sciences, also at Harvard
at the medical school.
He also received an MD
degree from UCLA in 2004.
Dr. Lin is currently a
professor at Stanford,
where he leads a
research group developing
protein-based tools for
imaging and controlling
biomedical processes.
He has a long string of awards.
And to me, most importantly,
he is the author
of what I consider as
the most viral slide deck
on COVID-19 in the recent days.
Michael, welcome.
Welcome to CSAIL.
Welcome to a MIT.
Welcome to the College
of Computing at MIT.
We're eager to learn from you.
Please go ahead.
Oh, great.
Hello.
Well, thank you
very much, Daniela.
Thanks, everyone, for
taking your time to join.
It's my pleasure to share with
you what I've learned myself
about the virus and the
disease in the last few weeks.
So you know, we're living
through unprecedented times.
We've seen nothing
like this since perhaps
the 1918 flu epidemic.
And I think it's useful for
us to all learn the facts
and try to spread knowledge
about the disease.
So I'm gonna get started and
share my PowerPoint window.
So some of you have
seen this slide deck.
Some of you have not.
And I understand
this slide deck,
I had made for my
own lab meeting
to basically ease anxiety
among my lab members
and use the facts to try to
put together a plan of action.
And so, now I'm happy to share
these facts with you as well.
And I'll try to explain--
I'll try not to get too deep
into the biochemical details,
but hit the most important
points along the way.
So as some of you
have seen, this
is not a pretty PowerPoint.
I haven't had the time
to make it really glossy.
It's not like a TED talk.
I'm not pushing a simple idea.
There's just a lot of facts.
But I think it's only
when you understand
all the facts together
that things make sense.
So we'll just get started
with some very general numbers
to put some context
into the numbers we're
going to get into shortly.
The total population of
USA is close to 330,000.
I've been doing a lot
of my calculations
based on numbers in California
because it's just easier for us
to think about it locally.
That's about 1/8 of the
USA, 40 million people.
So, you know, the
major causes of death
for young people in the
US are traffic accidents.
There's 30,000 per year
in the USA, about 3,000
for California.
For older people, actually flu
is the leading cause of death.
There are 40,000 deaths a year.
It's never really
known how much,
but the range this
year is estimated
between 22,000 and 55,000.
So out of that 40,000,
about 5,000 in California.
So for a population of
40 million in California,
you can use this sort of number
to get a general idea of how
lethal flu is.
If 25% of people got the flu
virus and only 5,000 died,
that's an infection fatality
rate or IFR of 0.05%.
It's probably actually more
like 0.1%, that is more
like 12% of the population might
get the flu virus in a given
year because we have flu shots.
So is everything OK?
You guys can see the
slides, Daniella?
OK.
Yes, everything is going great.
Thank you very much.
Yes.
OK, great.
So we'll get right into
some quick definitions.
The disease name is COVID-19.
I think we have all seen this
term much more than we want.
Technically, it refers to
the disease, not the virus.
In practice, the term
"cases of COVID-19"
are used to refer to
having a positive lab test,
whether or not
you have symptoms.
For reasons that are
partly political, partly
medical, if you just have
the symptoms, you know,
you're not necessarily
yet a COVID-19
case because you could have,
for example, a bad case of flu.
So you tend to wait for
the lab test results.
The WHO, the World
Health Organization,
introduced the name COVID-19
after holding the world
in suspense for a few
weeks, saying how important
it was to get the name right.
And then when they
announced the name,
there was the name
for the disease,
but there was no
name for the virus.
And so everyone
started using COVID-19
as the name for the virus
because there was no other name
given by WHO for it.
So this has led
to some confusion.
Some allowed people use the term
COVID-19 to refer to the virus.
I mean, I guess that's fine in
a popular lay point of view.
But technically, it actually
makes a difference because when
we--
I'd like to talk about cases
of the disease and infection
numbers based on the
estimate of the virus.
And so I try to use
a different name
for the virus when possible.
I mean, I personally think
COVID-19 is a terrible name.
Because it stands for
"coronavirus disease 2019."
And who says, if you want
to talk about a virus,
you could call it
the COVID-19 virus.
That would mean
coronavirus disease
2019 virus, which is a
mouthful for saying nothing.
It basically reveals
that the disease name
has no informational value.
So previously, we
had named diseases
by some sort of
description as a disease.
So SARS was named
SARS because it
stood for severe acute
respiratory syndrome.
And actually this
disease is very
similar to SARS, both in
symptomology and in the agent
that causes it.
So the World Health Organization
could have just named
this SARS 2 and
that would have been
both accurate and descriptive.
So what is the
name of the virus?
It was initially
called 2019-nCOV.
That stands for 2019
new coronavirus.
And it was given by
some infectious disease
organization.
This hasn't been picked up
because it's a really hard term
to remember.
You don't usually
think of numbers
when you think of naming things.
So I think it's also
misleading because it
gives the impression that
this virus is actually novel.
It's not particularly novel.
And I would say it's the least
novel of the new viruses we've
isolated and sequenced.
The most interesting thing about
it is that it's not that novel.
And that's because it's
96% identical to the virus
that causes SARS in 2003.
So in fact, the
biological name for it,
the name for its sequence
is SARS coronavirus 2,
or SARS-CoV-2.
So we'll use this name
throughout my presentation.
And I like this name because
it reminds us that SARS-CoV-2
is very similar to SARS-CoV-1.
And so a lot of the
things that we've
learned about the coronavirus
one, which came out in 2003,
it's almost 20
years ago, is very
relevant to predicting
what would happen
with SARS-CoV-2 and COVID-19.
So I'll just say, if you
haven't realized it yet,
that I'm not a big fan of how
WHO has managed this crisis.
But WHO decided not to
name the virus SARS-CoV-2
for precisely this
reason, because it made
people think of SARS.
They wanted to obscure the
relationship between the two
viruses.
They thought it would be unfair
to call the virus SARS-CoV-2
and to call the disease SARS-2
because it would remind people
about SARS.
Actually, I think that would
have been a good thing to do.
And as scientists,
it's better to be
clear about what you're working
with, rather than trying
to create false distinctions.
So I call SARS-CoV-2.
So what our coronavirus
is, what our SARS-CoV-2,
I don't have a picture.
I mean, I think you've seen many
EM images, many illustrations
of the virus.
Like other viruses, it
looks like a little round
ball with little spikes
sticking out of it.
From the molecular biology point
of view, what's interesting,
important to know
is it's fully RNA.
It doesn't go
through a DNA phase
and that we're
actually very familiar
with this class of viruses
because they account for 10%
to 30% of the common cold.
And they're unusually
stable for RNA viruses.
So we're used to hearing
that RNA viruses mutate
very quickly.
RNA viruses will always be
less stable than DNA viruses.
But among RNA viruses, these
seem to be pretty stable.
For example, the coronavirus
OC43 causes the common cold.
It was sequenced
once in the 1960s.
It was sequenced from an
isolate from the 1960s.
And it was sequenced again
from an isolate in 2001.
And those only had two
amino acid differences,
six nucleotide differences.
So that's pretty amazing.
As you've probably heard, there
are many coronaviruses in bats.
And they seem to hop
easily between species.
So they're quite adaptable to
a variety of mammalian species.
So we had the Middle East
Respiratory Syndrome,
MERS virus, that hopped
from camels to humans.
The original SARS virus
hop from bats, probably
to civets and then humans.
And then this one most likely
came from bats, as well,
through some
intermediate animal.
And there's a bat virus
that is very closely
related to the SARS virus.
You can see that in
the bottom red arrow.
And I made this point
that the human cold virus
OC43 is very closely related
to this mouse hepatitis virus.
Actually, what's
not showing here
is there's also a
cow virus that's
very closely related to humans.
So either humans or cows seem
to have given laboratory mice
hepatitis.
So how might you
kill this virus?
Everyone wants to know
how do you kill it.
So it's an envelope virus.
It has a thin plasma
membrane that's
only two molecules
of lipid wide.
So that's actually
really easy to kill.
Anything that would dissolve
a lipid will kill the virus.
That includes soaps or
detergents, solvents,
organic solvents like
ethanol, isopropanol.
I like to use Windex
which is a detergent.
And bleach will kill it because
it just kills off proteins
and biological molecules.
So it's also sensitive
to temperature.
I mean, well, I should say
that the original SARS was
sensitive to temperature.
So the current SARS-2
is likely as well.
And there's some numbers
that you can look at.
For example, on the
bottom left, this
is a graph of how much
tighter reduction you get
with different temperatures.
Oh, I left my
temperature numbers off.
That's actually, I
think, 37, 33, and 28.
I'll have to put that back on.
And then the survival of the
virus depends on the surface.
So this is a paper that was
recently published in the New
England Journal of Medicine.
On smooth surfaces
like steel and plastic,
it survives for longer
than on porous materials
like cardboard.
So that means on paper
towels or napkins,
the survival should be
like cardboard or lower.
But also the viruses will get
trapped in these paper fibers.
So it's not easy to get virus
out of a napkin, for example.
And then it can be killed by UV.
So the amount of UV
in sunlight probably
is enough to kill SARS-CoV-2
by 90% after about three hours.
At the current--
Michael, could I
ask you a question?
Yes.
So I heard that the virus
can survive up to nine days.
The data here does not
take us to nine days.
Can you clarify?
Yeah, the data here
takes us to three days.
So most headlines will say virus
can survive up to three days.
Yeah, thank you
for the question.
You can see here on the
stainless steel and plastic
that there's--
the dashed line is the
detectable amount of virus.
So you could see
that at 72 you still
are a little bit
above detection.
And then at 96,
it's undetectable.
So a lot of places, a
lot of news headlines
will say three days.
That's true, that's a
three logged reduction,
so that's 1,000 fold.
I think it's fair to use--
It depends what you want to
use, 10-fold or 100-fold.
I use 10-fold because I
think your transmission
risks are significantly lower
once you've had a 10-fold drop.
So I have a follow-up
question, if you don't mind.
Yes, please ask it.
So we know that there is this
shortage of masks in hospitals.
So if we look at
this data, does that
mean that if we save the
masks for four days, then
they can be reused?
Uh, yes, correct.
That's right.
You know, they'll accumulate
dust and other things,
but as long as you can breathe
through them easily, in theory,
you can just set aside the
mask and wait four days
and pick it up again, yes.
OK, so should I move on?
Yes, please.
All right, yeah, so now that
we know how to kill the virus,
we might ask, how
does SARS kill us?
So as many of you know, you
get initial flu-like symptoms,
sore throat, cough, fever, and
aches, shortness of breath.
And for many, in fact,
probably most people,
they only have these symptoms.
The symptom onset is 48 days.
So it starts about a
week after infection.
In severe cases, it will
spread to the lungs and cause
pneumonia.
And that's shown
in the top image.
So this can be diagnosed by CT.
There's a wide variety
in symptom severity.
So about 50% are estimated
to be asymptomatic.
That's based on data
from the Diamond
Princess, the ship in Japan.
5% will require hospitalization
and supplemental oxygen
due to difficulty breathing.
And that 5% is taken
from sort of estimates
based on diagnosed cases
of 10% elsewhere adjusted
for the 50% rate of
asymptomatic presentations.
Michael, we have some
questions, if I may interject.
So one question is, is the
disease severity related
to the dose of virus exposure?
Yeah, that's a
really good question.
I suspect it is.
I haven't seen any data.
Because, obviously,
you can't dose people
with different
amounts of viruses.
But I suspect it is, perhaps.
What might happen is if you
get a lot of virus at once,
you'll have more immediate
infection in the lungs.
And you'll just start off
with a higher viral titre.
And then your immune system
is behind in the race.
And so an example
this is the doctor
who raised the alarm in Wuhan.
His name is Li
Wenliang, I think.
And, yeah, it's funny.
It's such a sad case.
Every time I say his
name, I start crying.
Because he was only
39 and he died.
So that was really unusual.
He was treating multiple
patients with the virus.
So it probably was because he
was breathing a lot of virus.
OK, a few more
questions, and Michael.
So does one maintain
immunity to the virus
if they go through it once?
Probably.
I mean, there's no
data that suggests
that you lose immunity.
So if it's like any
other virus, then it's
likely that you are immune.
I mean, SARS patients
have proven to be immune.
So I think we should work
with that assumption here.
Also, how long
after the infection
will you test positive?
In other words, you are infected
today, you show symptoms,
let's say, eight
days from today.
At what point will
you test positive?
Yes, you will
probably test positive
around four days, five days.
Yeah, so these are
great questions.
So what happens in the
course of the disease
is the virus will
land in your throat
and it'll start replicating.
And it's now a race between your
immune system and the virus.
So the virus might double
or it might-- well,
it's not doubling.
It probably has a burst
size of several thousand,
meaning one cell can put out
several thousand viruses.
It will do that over a maybe 18
to 24 hours, so about one day.
So the virus is
replicating really quickly.
For you to get a
positive PCR test,
you need to have a swab
that gets enough virus that
creates enough nucleic acid
in the reaction for the test
to detect it.
So my guess is
that you will need
to have the virus for
three to four days
before you have a positive test.
I will have one more question,
and then we'll pause.
There are so many
questions on the chat.
I will ask you
one more question.
We'll come back
to other questions
later so you can go on
with your presentation.
And so the question is what
is known about the disease
severity--
Hey, Jill, I was just reading
a question and I lost it.
One second, sorry.
It might have been
the question, what
is known about its
disease severity
with respect to MHC alleles?
What is known about
why some people are
more or less susceptible
to catching the disease?
Yeah, right, that's
a good question.
So some of it might have to do
with MHC alleles, as described.
Although-- Right, so
yeah, it could be that.
It could be differences
in innate immunity.
So your body's first
reaction to the virus
is to produce
cytokines and then have
cells that are infected
with the virus actually shut
down protein synthesis
so that viruses
can't reproduce as quickly.
So it's kind of like a
fire alarm, the first step.
That might differ
between people.
You know, you wonder
why kids don't have
severe effects from the virus.
So perhaps kids have a stronger
innate immunity response.
And it's only a few days
later that your T and B
cells are activated
in the antibodies
are produced by your B
cells in sufficient number
to block the spread
of the virus.
So the fact that some
people come through it
without any symptoms
at all, like kids
and like 50% of the population
in general, my guess is it
has to do with differences
in innate immunity.
And then how effective
you are in having
your adaptive immunity, so
that's your T cells and B
cells, that specifically
recognize the proteins
on the virus, how
successful you are
in getting those working
in clearing the virus may
have to do with MHC alleles.
It may have to do with how many
white blood cells you have.
It certainly seems to be more of
a problem as people get older.
Thank you.
We'll pause.
We'll come back to questions
after we hear more of the talk.
Go ahead.
Sure.
Yeah, so when it gets
really bad is when you
need mechanical ventilation.
And that's about half the cases
that require hospitalization
begin with.
And then, you know, when
people die of the disease,
it's due either to
direct breakdown
of the alveoli in the lungs--
and there's a photo of
that in the bottom right--
or you have this massive
release of cytokines
by your immune cells.
Because now you've recruited
billions of immune cells
to your lungs.
And they're all trying
to fight the virus.
And they release a lot of
cytokines, which actually
can cause low blood pressure and
multi organ failure, especially
kidney failure.
So, you know, this is a slide
deck that I had put on the web.
And I have links for
all the facts, just
to make sure the facts
are double checked
and for more information.
So if you go to my Twitter feed,
which is MichaelZLin, all one
word, Z as in
zebra, MichaelZLin,
It's a pinned tweet.
You can download the slide
deck from there in the future
if you want to browse
through any of these things.
So yeah, it doesn't make
for a pretty presentation,
but I think it makes for a
more informative document.
All right, so now a lot of text.
So what everyone wants to know
is, what is the probability I
will get the disease?
Like, how many people
have the disease.
And that's impossible to
know from looking at the case
numbers.
So this is something
where the news
will report the case numbers.
It's misleading.
The case numbers are always
less than the infection numbers.
So if you want to know
infection numbers,
I think we have to go by--
We have to estimate the
probability of death
and work back from there.
So how do we know the
probability of death
from infections?
Well, you could start
with some good data.
So you could start
with a place that
has done the most testing per
capita, and that's South Korea.
So right now in South Korea--
well, what you can see in
this graph in the middle
is the number of cases
diagnosed in orange.
And the number of
deaths is in red.
So it looks like there's
a small number of deaths.
But actually, we know
that deaths, on average,
lack diagnosis by two weeks,
and this means infections
by three weeks.
It's actually two to
three weeks or infections
by three to four
weeks, with diagnosis
tends to happen around
one week after infection
when the symptoms first start.
So if you look at the
death and case curves,
the death curves indeed lag the
case curves by about two weeks.
So this case curve, as you can
see, is sort of flattening out.
It's reaching sort of a constant
rate of about 100 per day.
But the death curve looks like
this curve from three weeks ago
or two weeks ago, which
is right around here.
So it's still sort of in
this inflection point.
It doesn't yet flattened out.
That's the death curve
I just mentioned.
So the current
total deaths occur
from cases diagnosed
two weeks earlier ago.
So if we have 75 total
deaths last week and out
of 4,000 cases
two weeks earlier,
that's a case fatality
rate of about 1.9%.
But we know that infections
have to be at least
greater than the number
of diagnosed cases.
So that means the true
infection fatality
rate is less than 1.9%.
And it just depends on what
fraction of the infections
were diagnosed at, you
know, two weeks ago.
So it's somewhere below 1.9%.
Can I ask you something
about that, Michael?
Mm-hm.
I've been watching the Johns
Hopkins real-time cases
website.
And they report that
for the resolved cases,
the rate is more like 10%.
How should we think about that?
The closed cases
are the cases that
ended either in the patients
being fully recovered
or in death.
Yeah, well, I think they're
just slow to resolve the cases.
If you have a severe case,
it takes about a month
to fully recover
free of symptoms.
And, you know, these
resolution numbers,
I'm not sure how they're done.
They might be waiting for
people to be free of symptoms.
But maybe they just
don't follow up
in the large
proportion of cases.
My guess is they're
not following up.
It's just people are too
busy dealing with new cases
to worry about what
happened to the old ones.
So yeah, the case
closure numbers,
resolution numbers have been
low for all the countries.
So how else can we get this IFR,
this all important infection
fatality rate.
So an analysis of Chinese
data gave an IFR of 0.5%.
Some people doubt the
reliability of that data.
I haven't looked at it myself.
But the analysis of
the Diamond Princess,
that's the ship in
Japan again, gave 1.2%
as the infection fatality rate.
Now, on the Diamond
Princess, some patients
may have been helped with this
new medication remdesivir.
But also those passengers
were on the old side.
And we know old people
are more impacted.
So I think that 1.2 is
sort of a good estimate.
Also, you could look at
population distribution.
So if you look at the
number of people over 60,
there's more in
Korea than in the US.
And there's more in
the US than in China.
So I would guess that the IFR
for the American population
is probably around 1%.
So an estimate based on age
adjusted data from China
also gave a very
similar number, 0.9%
in the range of 0.4 to 1.4.
So the range shows
you how difficult
it is to really pick a number.
But let's just go with 1%.
All right, so we'll
move to the next slide.
Oh, I need to click.
OK.
So as everyone knows,
death is much more likely
for the older population.
So that's
unfortunately the case.
It's not that, you know,
the same is true with flu.
So it's not a surprising fact.
But you can see that,
and like the flu,
it seems to be much worse.
Now, this again, I
think, is actually
death rates out of
total diagnosed cases,
without a two or
three week time lag.
So this might be
actually a little bit
of an underestimation,
meaning that the denominator
cases might in actuality be
smaller than is shown here.
So this makes the disease
much more severe than the flu.
Michael, we have an
interesting question.
Right.
Is there any reason
beyond age distribution
why IFRs would be
different across countries?
So we've heard that in the
US, mostly younger people are
experiencing severe disease.
Yeah, some young people
experience severe disease.
But I think it's still a small
proportion out of the total
infected in the young people.
I haven't heard of good data
for differences in the age
distribution of severity.
There certainly will be some
country-to-country data.
In countries where older people
are more likely to smoke,
they ought to be more impacted.
So maybe that's a little bit
of a difference, like maybe
in South Korea older people
have a smoking history,
whereas that's less
likely in the US.
But I think we lack
the data on that.
Also, can the virus mutate
into being more deadly?
We've heard that maybe
there are two strains
and there are worrisome
numbers in France.
It's not clear if
there are more strains.
What can you share about that?
Yes, it can mutate to be
more deadly, in theory.
There's no particular
reason to think
that it will get selected
for that, though,
meaning, well, viruses
actually don't want to kill
their hosts too quickly.
They'd rather the host
stay healthy and just
be coughing a lot.
So there's no reason,
in particular,
to be very afraid
of that yet, right?
So meaning, the virus
is known to be stable.
It's known to adapt to a
bat host in a stable manner.
I don't think there's any
reason that it would be selected
for increased fatality.
So right, so I made an
estimate of how many new cases.
We don't have to go
through the numbers.
But basically you
take the current--
I split it up into weeks.
I go week by week.
I take the number of
deaths in the last week
and I multiply by 100 to
get a number of infections
that happened in the week
ending four weeks ago.
And I do this at the end of each
week to update the slide deck.
So this smooths out
day-to-day differences
in the reporting of deaths.
And it also doesn't
require any calculus.
It's basically a
numerical analysis.
It's like doing Riemann sums
with a time interval of a week.
So what you need to know is sort
of the rate of new infections
each week.
So if there were, for
example, in California,
there were 10 this week,
10 deaths this week.
That means there were 1,000
new cases four weeks ago.
With a doubling time of the
infection of seven days--
somebody people have
estimated six days.
I just used seven so we could
sort of make the analysis
simpler.
With a doubling time of seven
days, then from four weeks ago,
we're now 16-fold higher in
the rate of new infections.
There are probably
16,000 new infections
in the last week in California,
which is one in 2,500 people.
And then in the Bay Area, we're
more impacted in other regions
of California.
So I just assume its one
in 1,000 in the Bay Area.
Now, what can you
do when, you know,
you're in Boston, which
is also heavily impacted?
So it might be also something
like one in 1,000 people just
got the virus in the last week.
So what does that mean?
Well, 50% of people
will be asymptomatic.
So they'll never know.
And this is based on, again,
the Diamond Princess data.
It's also based on some
mathematical analyses
of the China data and of data
from passengers on evacuation
flights back to the US.
So 50% people will never know.
The average incubation
is seven days,
but the transmission may begin
two days before symptoms.
So that means a large
portion of people
will start transmitting
the virus without knowing,
even if they do
eventually get symptoms.
So that means you have
a risk of one in 1,000
from direct personal
contact, perhaps, and higher
than that from touching objects
that are commonly touched,
which are called fomites.
Those are things
like door handles.
And the risk of contracting
it from touching fomites
is in proportion to the
number of people touching
that between cleanings.
So you know, if 100
people touch that door
handle before you
touch it, now that risk
is increased to 1 in 10.
So that means we
have to take action
to reduce the risk of acquiring
the virus, either directly
or from touching.
So what would happen
if we did nothing?
So obviously, exponential growth
will continue with a doubling
time of one week.
And you can do a quick,
simple model as shown here.
This is very amateur model.
Most of you can
do better models.
Again, I didn't
want to do calculus,
so there are no equations.
It's just doubling.
And then we reach a point where
we run out of people to infect.
And according to this
model, that's in late May.
And California officials
estimate 56%, you know,
total infections.
Angela Merkel famously said 70%.
So it's something
between 50% and 70%.
At that point, the virus
runs out of targets
and it's harder for the virus
to find new people to infect.
Everyone else has been immune.
So that makes the
top infection rate
about 20% for the
last two weeks.
And then four weeks
after that, we'll
have deaths that result from
that 20% infection rate.
And that's huge.
So if you accumulated all the
deaths, those numbers shown
here in California, you have
to multiply by 8 to get the US.
That would be 2 million
cumulative deaths.
Again, this is really
just an amateur, back
of the envelope calculation.
But I think it's better than
other back of the envelope
calculations that you've seen
because it uses reported death
numbers and this estimated IFR.
Professional models say 100
million cumulative infections.
That's 30% or you could say
56% in the case of the one that
was done for California.
An estimated IFR of 0.5 as
a conservative estimate.
So I think my estimate
is not too far off.
It might be the worst case
scenario would be the 60%
and the 2 million.
But it could be better.
And there's some nice sites
for following case numbers
and fatality
numbers if you want.
So compared to the flu, which
had a cumulative infection
rate of 27% and
an IFR of 2%, this
is probably similar
in total numbers.
But the flu was
famously devastating.
The disease itself is probably
worse now than the flu.
Because back in 1918, they
didn't have ventilators
or drugs or antibiotics.
So this is why we need to
famously flatten the curve.
There are an estimated 5%
will require hospitalization.
And 2.5% of those will
require ICU and ventilation.
And the average hospital
stay is three weeks.
So that means that in the
last three weeks of May,
we'll get 10%, 20%, and 20%
of the population infected.
And then that four
weeks later in June,
will results in 1.6 million, 3.2
million and 3.2 million people
needing hospitalization.
And due to the three
weeks that they
need to stay in the
hospital, that's
eight million overlapping
at the same time,
compared to one
million hospital beds.
So that means we should slow
down the doubling time from one
week to at least eight weeks.
Of course, the
slower the better.
So that makes the
next month critical.
And that's why California
is shutting down
and Boston, I think,
has shut down.
Because we need to know how far
down we can get the R0, which
is the reproduction
number or how much
we can increase
the doubling time.
And due to the delay between
infection and diagnosis
and hospitalization, it
will take us several weeks
to know if it's really working.
And the hard deadline for
this is really early May.
Actually, I should
update the slide.
I think it's no longer May 16th.
I think-- let me go back.
I guess you could say
it's around May 15
that it would still be bad.
But, you know, it won't
require martial law yet.
But if you got to
May 15th, you would
have to basically confine
people to their homes
by threat of arrest because
otherwise any further infection
would overflow our
medical system.
So what can flatten the curve?
So I'm optimistic that
weather will help.
It's not gonna help a lot, but
it's gonna help a little bit.
So based on that graph
from earlier, a 10 degree
rise in Fahrenheit will
increase the doubling time,
will lower the amount of
virus survival by two-fold.
So I think it should--
I would assume it would increase
the doubling time two-fold.
So actually, I gotta
correct myself.
A 10-degree change, I
think, increases the amount
of death tenfold of the virus.
So I think it should
increase the doubling
time at least two-fold.
And in this, you'll also
get people outdoors,
so keeping them apart.
So that's why the flu is
seasonal, for example.
So the goal is to reduce the
reproductive number R0, which
is the amount of people
infected by each patient to 1.0
or lower.
The current rate is
estimated to be two.
And the sequential infection
interval is about seven days,
you know, basically, starting
from around when shedding
occurs at five days to when
symptoms start at seven days.
So if one present infects
two others in seven days,
that would explain the
doubling time of one week.
So dropping R0 to zero
would make the doubling time
infinite.
And drops in between
one and two will
increase the doubling time in
proportion to the dropping R0.
So you know, we have been
able in other countries
to drop the R0 to 1.0, to
a constant very small rate
of new cases in South
Korea, Taiwan, Singapore,
and Hong Kong.
And that's actually without
shutting down the economy.
That's by doing social
distancing, very, very robust
testing and tracing and very
strict hygiene, especially
the use of face masks and being
very careful what you touch.
Michael, I wanted to follow
up with a couple of questions
from the chat.
People are wondering, Wuhan was
very successful in flattening
their curve.
Why are the rest
of us struggling?
What should we be doing more?
Right, I think it's
too early to say.
You know, in California
we just implemented
the lockdown on Tuesday.
It will take--
And the cases are ramping up.
So a lot of the increase
you see in the case numbers
is just due to testing.
And that's probably
true even in places
like Italy where they've had
a lockdown for a little bit
longer.
So yeah, you know,
as a reminder,
I was to get infected today,
I wouldn't show symptoms--
If I was to be infected
today I wouldn't--
And if I were to
show symptoms, I
wouldn't show symptoms for
another five to seven days.
And currently there's a
delay in the US testing.
So I probably wouldn't be
tested for another seven days
after that.
So now there's
this two week delay
between when infections start
and when testing is complete.
So we won't see any change to
the R0 or the doubling time
at least for another two weeks.
And in fact, from
news reports, it
seems like most
people with symptoms
are being told to stay at
home to see whether they
get better or worse.
They're basically not testing
unless they get worse.
And so that means a large
proportion of mild cases
are being missed right now.
As testing expands, it
expands to those mild cases
or expands people who are
just household contacts.
And then that's gonna explode
the number of diagnosed cases.
So that means we're not gonna
see a reduction by looking
at the case numbers.
The only way we could
see a reduction, I think,
is looking at the death numbers.
Because those will
follow the infections
by three to four weeks.
But that's still a
faster time window
than the ramp-up of the
testing appears will be.
Michael, lots of other questions
and activity on the chat.
Let's see, can you make a
comment about face masks?
Yes, we're getting to it.
Everyone in Asia says
you must use face masks.
It's the only way.
In the US, we're told face
masks don't help at all.
Yes, I have four
slides on face masks.
OK, we'll wait on that, then.
OK, let's see.
OK, one more question.
What is the best case scenario?
You told us the
worst case scenario.
What is the best case
scenario for recovery?
Yes, in terms of
numbers, I assume?
Right.
I mean, the best case
scenario for a person--
[INAUDIBLE] in numbers, yeah.
Yeah.
Right, so the best-case
scenario for a person
is asymptomatic disease.
The best scenario for
recovery without vaccines
is probably something
like the next line
in the slide I was
going to get to,
which is complete
household isolation.
Like, for the country.
Michael, for the country.
Oh, for the country.
What's the best-- let's
say everyone stays at home.
What's the best-case scenario?
How many more weeks to
recovery from where we are?
Right, so I think if
everyone stays at home,
it's likely we can limit
the R0 to something like 1.0
on average, maybe even lower.
So in Wuhan, they did
complete household isolation,
which is similar to what
we're doing now in California,
except they probably
have fewer exceptions
for vital industries.
So here in California,
we have exceptions
for a whole slew of essential
industries, including,
marijuana dispensaries.
But in Wuhan, they had
complete house isolation.
And, you know, they took
infected household members
to central quarantining
locations or hospitals.
And they practiced
strict hygiene.
And this dropped the
R0 from 3.9 to 0.32.
And now Wuhan or China is
reporting no new cases.
Some people doubt
that's actually true.
But regardless, they
have a large drop
in the number of cases.
So if we practiced complete
house isolation, then,
you know, the disease
would go away.
But that would require
complete stoppage
of even essential industries.
So I don't think that's
likely in the US.
But it's possible we can drop
the R0 to something like one.
And then once better drugs
or a vaccine comes along,
then it would be safe.
The big fear is pre-symptomatic
or asymptomatic transmission.
In Wuhan, when they took
the symptomatic patients out
of the home, the R0
fell from 1.3 to 0.32.
So this suggests that only
24%, or that fraction, 0.32
over 1.3, of transmission
events occurred before symptoms.
But another study estimates
that 44% of transmission
is in the
pre-symptomatic period.
That's done by modeling.
So, you know, I'm
not able to evaluate
those models or the quality of
the data behind those models
so I don't know how
good those numbers are.
But, you know, we can assume
something like 24% to 44%,
or maybe a third of
transmission events
occur before getting
symptoms, without symptoms.
So how about completely
asymptomatic patients?
So the undiagnosed carriers
are estimated to be about 50%
as infectious as
the diagnose cases.
The undiagnosed
carriers in this study,
which was just published
in Science this week,
include people who will
eventually get the disease.
So that's not
completely asymptomatic.
But undiagnosed
carriers are more
likely be asymptomatic than
diagnosed ones, obviously.
And 50% of people
who get the disease
seem to not have
any symptoms at all.
So this implies that
asymptomatics are not
as infectious as
symptomatic people.
So go to the next slide.
Yeah, so how effective is this?
We talked a bit already
about the China,
South Korea, Taiwan,
Singapore experiences.
But you can see that
here on this graph.
The y-axis is log scale.
So that means a line would
be exponential growth.
And so you could see that
some countries are still
on a line, like France, like
Japan, actually, and the US.
But others have become stable.
Again, this is case numbers.
So some of the initial growth
in cases, especially in the US,
is just from faster testing.
So everyone wants to
know if there are drugs.
So this is the part where
I probably will go quickly.
Because this is mostly done
for a biochemical audience.
But I'll say that there
are a few drugs that
are very likely to work.
So one is this drug
that's already approved
in Japan for pancreatitis.
It's an emitter of a class
of enzymes, proteases,
that are required for
entry of the virus.
And what's interesting is it
was tested in cell culture.
And it has wide ability
to block the replication
of all sorts of
coronaviruses, including
SARS-CoV-1 and SARS-CoV-2.
And that's shown here
in the bottom left.
It's also been tested
against the original SARS
virus in mice.
So it's always nice to
see things tested in mice.
Because the main barrier
to a drug being effective
is getting high enough
concentrations in vivo--
I mean, not having
any toxicity in vivo.
Things that are
toxic to humans often
show up in toxicity in mice.
So it's a good proxy for humans.
So you can see here that
this drug camostat reduced
the amount of death from
SARS-CoV-1 infection in mice,
compared to nothing at all.
So another one is
this anti flu drug
called Avigan or favipiravir.
And this is a drug
that gets converted
into a ribonucleoside, which
is the building block of RNA.
And so then it gets used by
the virus RNA polymerase.
And the virus is now unable
to replicate its genome,
or at least not able to
replicate it correctly.
The idea is it creates so many
mutations during replication
that the virus eventually
fails to replicate.
So this, again, works
against the current virus
in human cells.
And then it actually seems
to have really poor potency.
We use a concentration
required for a 50% inhibition
as a benchmark for the potency.
This number is
actually really high.
You usually want it to
be below one micromolar.
This is 62 micromolars.
But actually, you
can load this drug
to a high dose in humans, 400
micromolar in your blood, which
is really high,
with just a pill.
So this is really efficient.
And it was declared
two days ago to be
effective against the
virus in controlled trials
by Chinese authorities.
No data was provided,
so we don't really
know how good the data was.
But it sounds promising.
This one Kaletra, down here,
is an HIV protease inhibitor.
It was thought that maybe
because the SARS virus also
uses a protease, a
protease is an enzyme that
cleaves to other proteins.
And it's required to process
one big protein in the virus
to many different
parts, individual parts.
Sorry, excuse me.
It was thought that maybe
this HIV protease inhibitor
would be useful.
And there was anecdotal
experience that it was useful.
But it turned out, just
announced two days ago--
and I haven't had time
to update the slide,
and I will right after
the presentation--
that the controlled
trial failed.
And so that shows the importance
of doing controlled trials
and not relying on
anecdotal evidence.
And I always thought that
this rationale was very weak.
So I'm not surprised
that it failed.
Chloroquine is getting
a lot of press today.
And I think it's
long overdue press.
It again has shown to
inhibit viral replication
of the current virus
in cell culture.
And a whole month ago, the
Chinese Health Ministry
said that it was superior
to control treatment
in multiple trials in China.
But again, no data was shown.
And actually, I'm not sure
why they don't show data when
they make these announcements.
It's a little strange to me.
I actually-- Yeah.
They're cynical reasons that
they might not be doing it.
Or it could just be
a cultural thing.
But in any case, they
haven't shown the data,
but they made the announcement
that it was useful.
And then just two days ago,
basically, the same conclusion
was reached by a French group.
It showed that it was
effective in reducing
viral titers in patients
in an open-label trial.
But chloroquine and it's
relative hydroxychloroquine,
they're both similar.
They're both anti
malarial drugs.
They do have some side
effects which can be serious.
But they have been safe to
use for preventing malaria.
You know, I think, you know,
it's funny when the press says,
oh, it's not proven.
Yeah, maybe we
shouldn't use it yet.
I'm like, well, you don't
have to wait for FDA approval.
It's already a drug that you
give for malaria prevention.
The current disease
is a lot worse
than malaria in some respects.
So I don't see why we wouldn't
just go on and use it.
Another drug that gets a
lot of press is remdesivir.
And that's because
it's probably the most
specific of the current
antivirals for SARS-CoV-2.
So remdesivir, It's
another prodrug
that gets converted
into a ribonucleoside
and is used by the
RNA polymerase.
It was originally designed
to inhibit the RNA polymerase
for another RNA virus, Ebola.
But it was shown in
a published paper
to inhibit the SARS-CoV-1
RNA polymerase and the virus
replication in mice
very effectively.
And it also works in human
cells on the current virus.
And that's not surprising
because the two viruses
are 96% identical at
the amino acid level.
So for most purposes, you could
think of the SARS-CoV 1 and 2
biochemically as
essentially the same.
And so now it's being tested
in humans in multiple trials
in the US and in China.
The China trial data
are due in a few weeks.
And now it's gotten a lot
of good anecdotal results.
But again we should
not rely on that.
That's why we have
the controlled trials.
So this is a lot of text.
But basically, I
should just note,
that they are drugs just to
treat the symptoms and not
the virus.
So it does this often from
cytokine release syndrome,
as we mentioned.
And there are drugs for that.
And so China has
approved one of them,
which is a Roche antibody
against a cytokine to prevent
cytokine release syndrome.
There's poor evidence, but
some evidence that COX-2
inhibitors--
that's just Vioxx and
Celebrex which were previously
prescribed for arthritis--
can prevent cytokine
release syndrome.
But no one's really
brought that up recently.
Again, like, treating
this is good,
but it's not as
good as preventing
the virus in the first place.
There's this big
raging debate going
on in the medical community
about ACE inhibitors.
And I'm not going to cover it.
Because I think it's
really besides the point.
You know, internal
medicine doctors
love playing with
hypertension drugs.
And ACE inhibitors are
You know, some of
you are probably
on three hypertension drugs.
I mean, this is just--
internal medicine doctors
live for doing this stuff.
And they're fighting
with each other
over whether having more
or less ACE2 activity is
good for the virus.
I think it's a side show.
They're talking about
preventing lung injury
or decreasing number of
receptors for the virus.
I think it doesn't matter.
I'm not even going
to touch on it.
So I'm not even gonna cover it.
But anyway, there's a link
here for more clinical trials,
if you're interested.
So there's a whole
bunch of new things.
You can make antibodies
from patients
or you could screen antibodies
in libraries in vitro
and just produce antibodies
that will bind to the virus.
So this has already been
announced by two companies Vir
and Regeneron.
I'm sure there are many
more companies doing this.
This is a tried and true method.
This is why sometimes you get
a travel shot of immunoglobulin
before you go traveling
for different viruses.
So it can be quite effective.
And so, you can
also make more drugs
based on the ones that already
know, like that flu drug,
like the remdesivir.
And you can screen for
drugs, either in vitro
or virtually on a computer.
So all these things
are being done.
And then, of course,
what we really want
is a vaccine that we can give
to the entire population.
And the fastest right now
are these RNA-based vaccines
where they just inject
RNA into your blood.
And some of it goes
inside your cells
and your cells will
produce viral proteins.
And you'll enlist
an immune response
to those viral proteins.
So there's some more--
there's a nice-- for
chemists, there's
this review of all these
different approaches.
I wonder why we don't just fix
the virus with formaldehyde
and inject it, which
is how the first polio
vaccine was made by Jonas Salk.
And a fixed SARS one
vaccine was found
to be protective in monkeys.
And this has been
proposed for SARS-CoV-2.
It's not like nobody's
thinking about this.
So I'm guessing it's
been done in China.
It's been proposed in
this article that was
written by a Chinese scientist.
So I'm sure it's
being done in China.
But you don't hear anything
about this in the US.
You know, the CDC
has its own lab.
And they used to do
their own research.
I don't know if that's
been cut recently.
But if they're still
doing that, this
is what they should
be doing, just making
the fastest, simplest
vaccine and telling us
that they're doing it.
So that gets me to the
next point, which is--
actually, I should probably
skip the many failures
of the CDC and the FDA.
It's interesting.
You can read about it.
I need to look at the time.
Oh, we're out of time.
So let's skip this.
If you guys are interested--
Michael, we are still
interested and we're still here,
those of us who can
stay online will.
And you still have
a few minutes.
We'd love to hear.
Yeah, we're gonna get to face
masks, which is what was asked.
So here's a little table
of the symptoms of COVID-19
versus the other thing.
So it's good, it's
useful for knowing
how it's different from
the cold or allergies.
But basically, you
don't tend to have
the runny nose or sneezing.
But you have all the flu like
symptoms of a fever, cough,
shortness of breath,
headaches, aches.
So recommendations for hygiene,
there are many recommendations.
But essentially,
there are two types.
So the first type is being
careful to keep the things you
own and your own hands clean.
So I'm a liberal user
of hand sanitizer.
So the alcohol in hand sanitizer
will kill the bacteria.
So you hear these things
like, wash your hands often.
Don't touch your face.
Like, what does it mean?
How often is often?
Why can't I touch my face?
I'm gonna touch
my face right now.
It's totally fine.
Somebody freaked out the
other day when I did that.
I'm like, I'm at home.
Everything is clean.
So basically you should
establish clean zones.
This is similar to
like, if you ever done
surgery on an animal
or watched surgery,
obviously you sanitize
before surgery.
And then you have a clean zone.
Once everything is
clean, clean things
can touch other clean things.
So that means that you
should sanitize your hands
right after touching things
that are touched by others.
You should preferably
only use clean hands
to touch other people's things
or handing things to others.
But clean your hands
again afterwards.
And that means also sanitizing
objects you get, right?
So like, if someone drops
off something for you,
I would actually sanitize
the outside of the package.
If it's cardboard, I wouldn't
worry about it too much.
I would just leave
the cardboard there.
But if they're giving
you a smooth object
like, you know, yeah,
like a CD, you know,
something that can hold
the virus, I would wash it.
And sanitation means
washing with soap
or using hand sanitizer or
using Windex or using bleach.
And so again, if
you already have
something clean in your
house, you don't have worry.
You don't have to
keep on rewashing it.
You don't have to keep
on rewashing your hands
when you're at home.
Right, so people ask
about disinfectants,
you know, like Lysol or
things that have bleach.
These are made for large areas
that you can't really soap
and wash or put alcohol on.
If you can use soap
or alcohol, you
don't need to also
bleach something.
Like, no one tells you to put
your hands in bleach after you
wash them with soap and water.
So if you can wash an
object with soap and water,
you don't need to
quote/unquote disinfect it
with a disinfectant.
So I just keep my hands to
myself as much as possible.
Face masks-- short
answer is yes.
So the US are fond of saying
that they're ineffective
or that you shouldn't buy them
because caregivers need them.
But both of those statements
cannot be true simultaneously.
If they were ineffective,
then the caregivers
would not need them.
So they are effective.
So they block 95% of
viruses if worn properly.
And that's because viruses
are carried in droplets.
And basically, the
masks are filters.
So, you know, there's a study
done between surgical masks,
which is the simple, three-ply
masks that look like they're
made out of paper and cloth.
And then there's the cup like
masks, the N95 respirators.
The study said they're
actually similarly effective.
But the N95 respirators are
thought to be more effective.
So my recommendations
for mask use
are based on relative risks.
The reason we've been
told not to use them
is to save them
for the caregivers.
And because the risk that
you'll run into somebody who's
emitting virus in public is very
low, so basically one in 1,000
at the moment.
So if you're just walking
by yourself in public,
you'd be wasting a mask.
But I think they would
be useful when you're
in proximity with
strangers, so when you're
riding in an airplane, a
train, in an Uber or Lyft
because you don't know if
the driver may be contagious,
and especially if you're going
to go to a hospital or clinic.
So--
What about the store?
Yeah, so it depends on
how crowded the store is.
I avoid stores, so I don't
know how crowded they are.
But I think if you're
going to go in,
I would have a mask ready.
If you're going to
go to a supermarket
and you see that you have
to be waiting in line,
I would put on a mask.
And then if you're
immunocompromised
or you're elderly, it's probably
a good idea to put on a mask
any time you're in
public, just in case
the guy who's jogging
by you breathes on you.
So once the infection
rates climb, then it's
useful for everybody in public.
And then they're
absolutely recommended
if you're sick because you block
the acceleration of viruses
from a sick person.
So again, the only
controversy of masks
is due to its limited supply.
But I think people
are wising up to this.
The former FDA
commissioner Scott Gottlieb
just tweeted his
support for mask use.
So I think you can only
deny the facts for so long.
So this is sort of an example
of public health officials
giving people
partial information
that's deliberately misleading.
I think they've
been disingenuous.
And it's caused people
to lose trust in them.
You know, they should
just be honest.
You know, people are adults.
If you tell them masks
are effective but the rate
of infection right now is
so low and we don't have
enough masks to go around that
we'd like you not to buy them,
that makes complete sense.
But telling people you shouldn't
use them because they're not
effective for you, it's true.
But it's true only in a
very misleading sense.
And it doesn't
engender trust when
people find out the full truth.
So you just need
some filtration.
So if you don't have a mask
and the guy next to you
is coughing, then just put
your nose into your sleeve
and breathe through that.
I mean, I do that when I
go to the bathroom anyway.
It's a really smelly bathroom.
And you know from experience
that that blocks odors so it
must be filtering something.
And in fact, a study shows
that a t-shirt blocks
70% of virus-sized particles.
So that makes sense.
So I won't go into
this, how to use masks
and how to conserve
masks because I
think most people just want to
know whether it's a good idea
or not.
But I would say that in Asia,
like in Taiwan and South Korea,
China, Japan, it's
not just OK, it's
expected that you wear masks.
And in mainland
China, it's required
that you wear masks in public.
So even if they have a
very low infection rate,
they have enough
masks to go around.
Yes?
Michael, for what
it's worth, we're
trying to mobilize our alumni
network to help us with masks.
Because I think you're right.
It's important.
Yeah, I mean, the
US, you know, I mean,
the US is increasing its
manufacturing of masks.
But it's still slow at the
moment relative to need.
So the washable masks are
not as good as the N95,
but they're still good?
Well, the surgical masks and N95
masks are equally unwashable.
There's cloth masks that you
can buy, like allergy masks.
And again, they're probably
better than nothing.
But they're not as good
as surgical masks, which
are the three ply, you
know, flexible ones
or the cup-like N95 masks.
But on this slide, I
suggest decontaminating it
by heating it up in
the oven at 70 degrees
Celsius for 30 minutes
or putting them
in a UV sterilizer.
But as we mentioned
before, if you just
let them sit in a
clean place for a week,
the virus should be dead.
So I have a list of things
that I think are OK to do,
like visiting relatives
if you're really
careful with the hygiene steps.
But, you know, I
would definitely
recommend buying
groceries online
instead of in a grocery store.
You know, you can say, well,
the person who picks and packs
your grocery might be infected.
But the same is true in a
grocery store, the person who
stocks the items on the shelf
has the same chance of being
infected.
Plus, in a grocery store,
you have 1,000 other shoppers
going through and then the
cashier has to, you know,
touch the goods that
1,000 other shoppers have
selected and touched.
So it's better just
to reduce the number
of those interactions and
just buy your groceries online
if you can.
But that's about it.
So you know, travel
if necessary.
I think if you're armed with
hand sanitizer and masks,
you can travel.
Just be careful, you know,
with keeping your hands clean,
keeping your space clean.
And I would just end with this,
that because 50% of people
with virus have no symptoms
but will become immune
and because that
means 95% of people
don't go to hospital,
most people who
get the disease will recover
at home in about a week.
The workforce is not threatened.
So, you know, there will
be enough farmers and truck
drivers and store workers to
distribute food and sell food.
So you don't have to go out
and buy everything in sight.
So that's about it.
And in the next slide, as
you guys have seen online,
there's a recipe for how
to make your own hand
sanitizer if you're
not able to buy any,
out of just ethanol or
isopropanol and glycerol.
So that's it.
So I'm sorry to take so long.
Michael, this has
been fantastic.
Thank you so much for
taking time for us.
I wonder, do you have a couple
of minutes for a few more
questions?
Sure.
OK, so we don't want
to impose on your time.
But we do have a
couple of questions.
Actually, we have
a lot of questions.
Let me just start pick on a few.
Can you talk about the
possibility of reinfection?
Yeah, you mean like
getting an infected again
after you've cleared it.
Yes.
I think it's small.
You know, there
was this worry that
was because a woman had
recovered from the virus
and then left the hospital
with a negative test
and then got worse and
then got a positive test.
And it was taken as evidence
that you could clear the virus
and get reinfected.
But it's probably just the
negative test was negative.
I mean, she probably was
fighting the virus pretty well,
but then the virus rebounded.
So it's more a case of just
insufficient immune response
to the virus to begin with.
But if she cleared it the second
time and it's really clear,
then it should be fine.
Your memory, you know,
your B and T cells
take a week to ramp up.
But then your long-lived
memory B cells take something
like a month to differentiate.
So it has to do with the
switching of the types of IG,
immunoglobulin.
So there might be this window
where the virus can come back.
But it's less likely that you're
getting reinfected from outside
as it's just a low-level
infection inside.
So along similar
lines, what can you
share about the possibility
of recovering this summer
and fall, all the
students return to school,
and then we have a recurrence
that's even worse than what
we have now?
Yeah, so I think one thing that
public officials are not saying
yet-- well, they don't know
what's going to happen--
is that these kinds
of measures are
going to have to
be kept in place
until a vaccine or a very, very
effective treatment is made.
So you know, the RNA
vaccine, so we'll probably
know if they're
useful in six months.
But then, you know, it might
take another few months to ramp
up production and distribution.
So we're not likely to be
in time for a September
vaccination.
These drugs like chloroquine,
remdesivir, you know,
chloroquine you don't want
to really dose to everyone.
It's too toxic for that.
You might dose it to
high-risk populations.
Remdesivir is likely
to be in short supply.
It's probably only
50% effective anyway.
And so you don't want to rely
on the drugs too much entirely.
[INAUDIBLE]
What are the barriers to
manufacturing these drugs
faster and in larger quantities?
Chloroquine there's no barrier.
It's very simple.
The favipiravir also
looks pretty simple.
I'm pretty sure they
can be manufactured
for millions of people.
But the side
effects are probably
such that you don't want to take
it unless you really have to.
Yeah, and then remdesivir
looks more complicated.
That's probably
harder to synthesize.
But Gilead is upping
the production.
But again, these
drugs are not going
to cure everyone of disease.
And so they're more like
hospitalization medicine.
So they only for the 5% of
people go to the hospital.
And then maybe only 50%
of those who take the drug
will still be able
to fight it off.
And that's just a
guess at the moment.
It may be 75%.
So it's still going to be
a burden on the hospitals
unless we continue
to be careful.
What I would like to see
is us returning to work,
but just being more careful
like people are in Asia.
I think it's a public
education problem.
You know, in the US, the
local authorities don't even
bother trying a
course of education
before a course of lockdown.
Because they've seen
how people don't
react to proclamations of
staying away from crowded
places.
But, you know, in
Asia you can do it.
People are maybe much more just
much more scared of viruses,
more used to working in
tight environments, used
to things like wearing a face
mask and sanitizing spaces.
Can you also address briefly
the testing bottleneck and what
we can do to test more?
I admire how Korea
tested so many people.
And they have tests that come
around in 50 minutes, I hear.
What can we do here?
Yeah, I don't know.
Yeah, I'm not sure about
the 50 minute test.
I really don't know.
Maybe there is.
But that would be amazing.
What I saw in
articles about Korea
is that they, first
of all, the companies
took their own initiative
to develop tests early.
And then the health ministry
coordinated with many companies
to roll out multiple
tests at once
because they knew it might be
a big thing and they wanted
to be ready.
You know, Korea gets a lot
of visitors from China.
So they probably suspected they
would get a lot of infections
from China.
In the end, they got
most of their infections
from one patient, patient
31, who infected people
through her church.
So they were ready for that.
You know, in the US, part
of it is the federal nature
of the government.
Korea is still a
relatively small country
of 40 million people.
OK, so what's funny is
when China locked down
Wuhan in the province of Hubei,
that was 50 million people.
And I just read an interview by
Dr. Fauci where he was asked,
would that ever
happen in the US?
He was like no,
that's impossible.
We could never do that.
So now we've locked
down California.
That's 40 million people.
It's the size of Korea.
So it's possible to do it.
But in the US we
have 320 million
and the federal government.
And as we know, we have a
federal government that's been,
one, starved of
resources, and two,
ideologically reluctant to
spend a dime on any public good.
So it's just a complete failure
of our political system.
Well, I mean, let's
be honest, it's
a complete failure of one
set of people in charge.
Michael, you have a lot of
captive computer scientists
and engineers on this call.
What can computing
and engineering
do to help with this
difficult moment in time?
Yeah, that's a good question.
Not being a computer
scientist myself,
you know, I don't
want to give advice.
I think you guys
will figure it out.
You know, it's-- you know,
making cheap ventilators is
certainly one possible solution.
You know, using computer
science to work with biologists
to screen for drugs
or analyze genomes
is another possible solution.
Yeah, I think talk
to your colleagues.
Talk to your
colleagues in biology.
It's harder to do
that now that we
can't gather in the cafeteria.
But you know, we'll have a
few weeks of being at home.
It's possible to urge
your department chairs
to send messages to
their other colleagues
in other departments
asking if anyone
needs any assistance in
their research efforts.
Michael, thank you so much.
If you get any
computational challenges,
please reach out to us.
We would love to help.
And we really appreciate
you sharing your time
and your knowledge with us.
Thank you.
I'm gonna clap on
behalf of everyone.
Thank you very much.
Yeah, I appreciate your time.
Thank you so much.
OK, signing off.
Thank you.
Bye, everyone.
Thank you for joining us.
I hope you enjoyed the
presentation and you learned--